With Marla's help, we've covered some
of the key problems in US health care.
And some of the principal arguments for
the increased use of health IT.
Most health care is concerned with
the management of chronic diseases.
Proper management requires a highly
coordinated, more continuous approach to
care that welds together many providers
into a seamless delivery system.
At the center of such a patient-centered
system of care, is the primary
care physician whose role is knowing
everything about their patients so
they can coordinate their care.
In practice, this is very
difficult to achieve because of
the shortage of primary care
physicians here in the U.S.
and the large number of
providers who are involved.
Particularly in the care
of patients like Marla,
who have multiple chronic diseases,
coordinating this requires electronic
records ideally for the providers and
patients and the seamless exchange
of information among them.
This same information can be used to
manage the health of populations of
patients, or the public at large.
It can also be used for research
to gain new medical knowledge, and
even learn how we can
improve health care delivery.